[Music]
washington journal continues
we're joined now by richard allen who
served as the national security advisor
in the early years of the reagan
administration a longtime foreign policy
adviser to
former governor and then president
reagan and your piece appears in the
atlantic monthly it's called the day
reagan was shot and this story has been
getting a fair amount of attention this
past week why well to my great surprise
i don't know why it's getting the
attention but
i've been asked that question before and
i i i guess it's because the words
white house
assassination attempt
tapes
crisis
chaos
uh which is not an accurate description
of what was actually going on in the
white house probably all converge to
create some sort of interest but i'm
utterly astounded by the the level of
interest that it's created if you have
not yet read about this article this uh
uh article or about the situation which
led to it it's all based on some
recordings which took place march 30th
1981 where
in the white house um
there's a
a place called the situation room
there's a lot of myth about the
situation room it's basically a two-part
room
one is a very secure conference room
which is lead lined and shielded from
electronic eavesdropping
and then there's a communication center
and the situation room was set up
following the cuban missile crisis
when during that incident
president kennedy received an important
document from the state department three
days late
and he decided that he was going to set
up something that would an organization
in the white house that would be able
contemporaneously to read all of the
traffic that's coming in and to to have
communications be very efficient
and so it was set up in on the ground
floor some call it the basement of the
white house
and there we have secure communications
uh to every post in the world to the cia
the state department defense department
the conference room is where important
decisions are made and where very secure
and
secret conversations are held
and on that given day
i came back to the white house i had
been i decided to take a quick swim
instead of lunch and was pulled out of
the university club's
swimming pool by my driver who said we
had to get back and we did go back and
within five minutes i was at the white
house still putting my clothes on and
drying my hair
went to my office then went up to the
chief of staff's office jim baker
who with whose car i had nearly collided
on the way
back in at high speed and they were on
the way out high speed
the counselor of the president jim baker
the chief of staff to the hospital
and when i saw the the the mild chaos in
his office i took a few of those present
and
excluding all
non-essential staffers down to the
situation room behind
closed doors and electronic locks in a
guard
and we
conducted our business down there
what made you think amid everything that
was happening and the rapid pace in
which it was happening to record the
discussion
well i'm a i'm an escaped academician
and uh i suppose perhaps a sense of
of historicity of
the historical importance of the day
but since tape recorders are not
normally permitted or never permitted
in the situation roman in order to
maintain the sanctity of secrecy and
confidentiality
there was none available and so i simply
asked my chief assistant janet coulson
to go to my desk get my little battery
operated
sony tape recorder
a handful of tapes a handful of
batteries and bring them in where was
the tape recorder my office was adjacent
a few feet uh to the the situation room
and uh perhaps 20 feet and so she simply
went to get the tape recorder and
brought it to me and we were just
beginning to assemble and
the secretary of the treasury was there
secretary weinberger came and others
al haig the secretary of state was and i
simply
put the tape recorder and the stack of
tapes and the batteries in the middle of
the table and is this it right here
yes that's the uh that's the date of
recording did they know and there's
david gergen uh situated behind did they
know that you were well
wouldn't have ever had any business
being in the situation room normally i
mean
non-essential staffers are not in the
situation room uh did the others know
the director of central intelligence the
secretary of state yes of course they do
it was there in plain view there was i
want to emphasize this is not a
surreptitious tape
there's this is no secret to tape this
is not an illegal tape it is simply a
tape recording and it turns out to be
turned out to be very valuable one in in
the uh analysis of this this tragic
event that day we are uh putting the
recordings on our website at cspan.org
and if you're here in the washington dc
area you'll also have a chance to hear
it on c-span radio 90.1 on your dial but
here is a short excerpt of part of the
discussion between then secretary of
state al haig cap weinberger who was
defense secretary and richard allen
national security adviser
let me ask you a question there's
another one is this submarine approach
uh is that what's doing this or is it
the fact that the president's under
surgery
what's doing what else
that we are discussing whether or not to
put the kneecap bird up in the air i'm
i'm discussing from the point of view
that at the moment until the vice
president actually arrives here the
command authority is what
and i have to make sure that it is
essential that we do everything that
seems
it kind of reads the constitution all
right we can get the vice president
[Music]
one way or another uh the initial steps
because he's not in a position there to
take all of them without consultation
one way or another we ought to prepare
at least enough so that we
can uh
uh move more rapidly than we could
otherwise and uh so the discussion of
the kneecap is because of the submarine
or because of the incident that's the
question i'm asking the
reason that i asked to have the move to
the planes is because of the incident
and i would continue to take that
position until i know absolutely
definitely that it's an isolated
incident which i think it is
but i don't know that yet and i don't
want to take any kinds of risk there's
no the the risk of some newspaper story
or some rumor is a hell of a lot less
than not having the things in place
what was the relationship like between
cap weinberger and al haig
well
it progressed
that day from
collegiality
to
strained collegiality
and uh
it was
much is made of
the
alleged tensions that were uh prevalent
in the situation room that day
uh that's not the real story the real
story here is that
a group of people
in office just 60 days a little over 60
days
a new administration
and some of them strangers complete
strangers
work together efficiently
effectively not without some tension
to
make sure that everything was all right
that day especially on the national
security side and in that room with the
attorney general the director of the
central intelligence agency the
secretary of state the secretary of
defense i was there fred fielding the
council to the president martin anderson
the domestic adviser those are the
people that we wanted in that room uh to
be able to put their collective wisdom
to work and there were some
misunderstandings
but i don't think that anything was done
out of a spirit of malice or and the
fact that there was tension ultimately
some fairly
harsh tension
didn't deflect us from the main job at
hand our conversation is with richard
allen his piece appears in this month's
edition the new edition of the atlantic
monthly it's called the day reagan was
shot served as national security adviser
to former president reagan our phone
lines are open we'll get a call from
coconut creek florida good morning to
you caller
hi good morning
i have a comment and then a question
uh what i really wanted to say was
as all of us being americans
i think that we really need to wake up
uh most of us are working
americans
we're the working-class middle class
and george bus has done nothing
caller i'm going to stop you the it is
we're going to clear our phone lines
it's a little bit off topic we were
talking about uh taxes and budget issues
something that you dealt early in the
reagan year i'd like to talk about taxes
and continue the work that jim nussell
has done
what impact did the shooting of ronald
reagan have on his agenda here in
washington in march april and may of 81
oh i think that
if there is an upside or a sunny side to
a shooting if you can imagine such a
thing i think it
gave an enormous boost of momentum
to president reagan's agenda
not just out of sympathy but i think it
awakened attention to the importance of
that agenda and that was overwhelmingly
a domestic agenda at first
clearwater florida good morning to you
good morning i uh of course want to
compliment mr allen for his service to
our country uh during the first reagan
administration and one of the sidebars
that his tape
contributes is the strong
one might say egos another one might say
personalities
the strong wills of the men that
surrounded ronald reagan in his first
term especially jim baker cap weinberger
we heard and of course al haig doesn't
back up when anybody puts his finger in
his chest and
it kind of confirms the fact that ronald
reagan led all of these individuals and
that the idea that ronald reagan was
being led
really is
is deflated by your tape
well that
may i say that's a very important
comment in observation
um of course
there are strong-willed people
this is reflected once again in the the
new bush administration i think
and president reagan was a leader i
there's an interesting aspect to this
i spent a lot of time with president
reagan during the pre-campaign years the
campaign year and we traveled the world
and i traveled this country with him and
on the first day
of his administration
i came in to deliver the national
security briefing
and we'd only been in that office with
him the night before the evening before
of the inauguration so i came in in the
morning and there was a picture of nancy
reagan and the children on the credenza
behind him nothing on his desk except
the national security briefing
that i had presented earlier in the day
early in the morning
and we were about to discuss it when i
noticed as he was reading through it
leaping through it the other thing on
his desk was way in the right corner
front right corner so that people could
see it a little plaque
that said something to the effect
there is no limit to what a man can
achieve or how far he can go
as long as he doesn't mind who gets the
credit and that was his message on the
very first day in office to his staff
some people read that little sign and
heeded its advice
others ignored it i think ultimately at
their peril he was a leader he inspired
people to do their best and he kept
himself and the administration very much
on message and this was an extraordinary
thing and strong personalities if you
call them that or egos whatever they may
be
were submerged
by and large and for the most part
to support that president's agenda
because we had a sense of purpose who
ignored that advice
oh well you'd have to go through
the individuals themselves and ask them
i think it might be fairly self-evident
well in the long run you can find out
who who
public service is
a very appealing thing it either is a
stepping stone to power or it's an
opportunity literally to change history
and i think in the first reagan
administration
most of the people involved with the
president at the cabinet level and
senior staff were truly interested not
in career advancement or resume
enhancement but in literally changing
history and that's the great source of
pride that we see may make one other
comment that caller evokes the
importance of mentioning the new book
reagan in his own hand edited by kyron
skinner martin anderson and annalise
anderson of the hoover institution
this book is an extraordinary and
rev extraordinarily revealing in that it
shows that reagan's thought was shaped
long before he became president in his
own hand demonstrates clearly that
through the
actual transcripts of the radio
broadcast that president reagan made
some 600 of them were examined in some
250 are in this book you can actually
see in his own hand the strikeouts the
crossouts the formation of his thinking
by the way that is the subject of an
upcoming book notes and
an excerpt of
former governor ronald reagan's last
radio address will be shown also or
listen to as part of that booknotes
program you can check our website for
schedule information next call is from
lakeland florida good morning
good morning go ahead caller can you
hear me we sure can go ahead uh are you
familiar with the
jim mars
ruled by secrecy
if you're asking me i can't say that i
am
well it's like what happened to uh
president reagan who shot him and
and why
and
i think
president reagan was going to look in to
the secret society oh but then all of a
sudden
he didn't
they must have been occupied i think
with other affairs of state he has a
book he actually appeared on the program
a couple weeks ago talking about
different conspiracy theories
including uh conspiracy theory dealing
with a reagan assassination really did
you think at the time that you keep kept
talking about the submarine
and that's this is during the height of
the cold war was that a legitimate
concern that you had during the early
hours after the shooting
well i'd say it's very legitimate we
were in the cold war the president had
entered office he had delivered his
first
volley in his first press conference by
advising the nation that in the world
that the soviets would lie cheat and
steal to get what they wanted
um
this
situation in poland was very uncertain
we had had cloud cover and no reliable
photography overhead photography for
some time there were unusual troop
movements in and around poland a strike
was imminent by solidarity
we didn't know whether it would be a
soviet invasion um
there were just wasn't one submarine it
was a larger number of submarines than
usual and it took us a while
systematically to figure out why they
were there
and the reason was finally we deduced
that it was the 30th of march some were
coming in and some were leaving
we didn't know who had shot the
president what connections this person
may have had
whether it was a conspiracy or not
whether we should take extra precautions
in terms of alerts
so it was a very legitimate prudent and
responsible thing that especially that
secretary weinberger did that ultimately
led to some of the misunderstanding and
intention in the room not not generally
but just between the two of them
weinberger and hague
but kev weinberger was a pillar of
stability that day and did exactly the
right thing because he had the national
command authority the military authority
in the absence of the vice president
that had nothing to do with succession
uh who would succeed the president in a
certain line
so it was well done ed mies and jim
baker
were rock solid at the hospital theirs
was the true command center ours was the
nerve center
and while they were watching after
watching out for the the welfare of the
president and obviously deeply concerned
as we were we had another task to do
there and to make sure that there was
nothing beyond a single
uh conspirator in this assassination
attempt columbia south carolina good
morning with richard allen yes uh thank
you mr allen for your service to our
country it's a pleasure to talk to you
this morning i was wondering if you
could uh
address the
the relationship between secretary
weinberger and secretary hague
well um
of course i'm a third person i you'd
better it's best to talk to al hagar kap
weinberger about this but both are
extraordinarily able men both have
stellar careers and continue in their
careers and made enormous contributions
to to
to the united states at various times
and uh i won't attempt to recite all
that they've done it was it's it was a
pleasure always to serve with both of
them there were moments of tension there
are different personalities
cap weinberger is a
more or less laid back
soft spoken
very determined
and precise man
al haig is
highly informed
very eager to pursue
an agenda
had a complete understanding of the
world and foreign policy but is wound a
little tighter
than cap weinberger and
we shouldn't i want to emphasize again
we don't need to read too much into
these personality conflicts because that
doesn't affect ultimately
policy
there were two different approaches that
day and al has said that
he misspoke
and maybe there was some
misunderstanding on his part
but that doesn't negate
the overall contribution that he made
nor does in any way
impugn secretary weinberger these are
you just have to learn to deal with
different people
the day or two after you recorded the
conversation what did you do with the
tapes oh i
took them i guess i took them home they
were
i wanted them in safe keeping and i i
never intended to do anything with those
tapes
um until just recently we came up on the
20th anniversary and there were several
reasons not only the 20th anniversary i
knew that there were some fanciful
accounts of what went on that day
many of which were
put under the category of chaos reigning
there was no chaos
in the situation room nor was there
chaos where jim baker and ed meese were
at the hospital and mike deaver no it
wasn't chaotic at all there was chaos
and confusion over the fact that the
president had been shot but then there
was another matter
mr oliver stone is doing a movie
on this particular event i think it's
being shot now
and
knowing his record for accuracy
i did not want to allow
that to determine
the public consciousness of this event
and i thought it was more important than
ever to show that
the real story as to what happened in
the white house as to what happened in
the hospital is generally well known
what happened in that white house
situation room until now was not known
and finally 20 years is a decent
interval uh it's a good time uh to write
where are the tapes now um i suppose
around the corner here if you'd like to
see them i can show them to you are they
in the green room oh they may be in the
green room or it's just ordinary
cassettes so if you put hold up any
cassette it would look exactly like that
one if you haven't we'll show them
during the audience we'll get a call
from raleigh north carolina good morning
hi good morning to you both um mr allen
i was wondering if you have if you're
familiar with the christopher hitchens
articles uh
pretty much demonizing i guess casper
weinberg in the past to uh harpers
um i think he i think is i think chris
hitchens um
uh
articles and harper's recently uh are
demonizing uh henry kissinger not kat
weinberger
all right um well i was i was originally
asking um
what uh what with your one year working
with casper weinberger how how was your
opinion how was your relationship with
him at the time
um absolutely splendid cap weinberger
was a man that i first met
on a public television station back in
the 1960s when i was at the hoover
institution on war revolution and peace
at stanford university an organization
with which i am still affiliated and i'm
very proud of that affiliation that's
where my papers and all my
public and private papers will go for
the archives
and he was moderating a show on vietnam
we subsequently met when he came
to the nixon administration and i had
great respect for him there and when it
was decided to appoint cap he was very
close to reagan of course he was the
director of the budget in the california
years of when reagan was governor uh i
was
ecstatic that camp weingerberger was
made secretary of defense and we had a
very close uh warm
relationship and maintain it to this day
next call is from charleston south
carolina good
morning yes i'd like to i'd like to hear
more about the movie coming up with uh
oliver stone
uh you have spoken about his accuracies
you know i assume you're talking about
the movie he made with of course the
most famous one jfk
did you elaborate on
on why
oliver stone
and the accuracies that he's
been known for has attracted you to
doing this movie
well you're not doing the movie no i'm
not doing the movie and i haven't been
asked to star in it yet and usually the
national security advisor uh in every
movie is is a bad guy he usually has
glasses he's probably a little chubbier
than he should be
and um he's he's always involved in a
very uh uh
[Music]
i should say a very deep conspiracy
but uh i'm not a uh that much of a
moviegoer but um given as i mentioned mr
stone's uh track record for historical
accuracy i think it would be a wise idea
uh for us to um
uh be careful and and uh make sure i
wanted to make sure that the record is
set straight before his uh movie uh it's
either the theaters or television and uh
i don't i wouldn't expect that he would
even bother to uh to talk to me about
the accuracy level i'm not gonna go
through your bag but i'm told that
they're in your bag just told you that
they're in my
bag take a look if they are we'll show
our audience the tapes in the meantime
we'll get a call from petersburg
virginia good morning oh yes
yes sir good morning to stay on it good
morning i'm going to ask you a question
and i hope i can praise it right and i
want to get it right and answer i want
you to tell me the connection between
the hinckley family and the scott henry
on the day of the president rashad
john hinks's brother
and scott hinkley who is scott hinckle's
brother and neil bush were very close
friends they were singing together in
washington today
they had a dinner engagement for that
evening
well i that that's a revelation to me um
i
if neil bush was close to
uh uh mr hinckley's john hinckley's
brother scott hinckley about whom i've
not heard very much i haven't been aware
of it but i think it's something that
historians will look at
and just to give our audience a sense
this is i didn't authorize you to talk
i'm sorry
just put it over the camera i won't
touch it again i promise
some scribbling on here what does it say
well i don't know
um
crisis 20 that's my writing crisis 20
march
so it's a simple 90-minute memorex
cassette tape
just a simple little 90-minute janet
colson my um
my top associate my aide uh special
assistant tells me that she has a
picture
of
of her and of me
at the end of this crisis with
either her with a janet or me holding
the tape with a smile on her face
meaning we had a good record and it was
important to have that record this
record
really authenticates and will hopefully
be a new point of departure for all
historians who write about this incident
and you know the the remarkable thing
about it all is not the incident but
ronald reagan was strong enough to
withstand that and recover and come back
in full swing it must have certainly
done a great deal for his legacy also a
testimony to his physical fitness
we're talking with richard allen who
served as the national security advisor
in the early years of the reagan
administration atlanta is next good
morning
good morning sir
i would like to know
if
mr allen would admit
or
say that most of the people he's
speaking of and probably himself are
members
of the committee of foreign relations
the trilateral committee
the bilderberg group and the skull and
bones okay that's a
that's a very good question i have to
tell us can i tell it in the context of
a story
president reagan
well
campaigning
in early very early late 1979 it was
a pre-campaigning
ronald reagan went i think to alabama
i was with him we flew in a small plane
and
we
at the on the tarmac either getting on
or off that plane
he was a question was put to him uh what
about the trilateral commission well i'm
not a member of the trilateral
commission and uh i'll also tell you a
quick story about the council on foreign
relations but um
he sort of stumbled his way through the
question we got back on the plane and he
leaned over to me and he said what in
the heck is the trilateral commission
i said was part of the vast
left-wing conspiracy to take over the
world and i mentioned you mentioned the
bilderberg group uh that's exactly right
that these um organizations are thought
by some to be heavily conspiratorial and
i didn't belong to any of them until
recently i did join the heavily
conspiratorial council on foreign
relations
and
had a good time ever since but i'm i'm
not conspiratorially minded when's the
last time you saw ronald reagan
uh i think it's been almost three and a
half years or four years
since i'd seen the president i'd seen
him at the at a gathering at the
bohemian grove
and maybe even been longer than that and
i saw him one of the time in his office
about about four years ago
and
i'd love to see him again
because i have such a strong affection
for him
what do you remember about that meeting
uh
well
i guess now that i think of it it may
have been
here in washington
i remember that
in mentioning an incident to the
president
uh he had it was a funny incident it
occurred in 1978 in germany on his first
trip to germany which i had arranged for
him and peter hannaford his one of his
top and longtime aides but there nancy
reagan irene hanford and my wife pat
and this was a very funny answer that he
remembered all through his presidency
and i asked if he remembered
driving down the autobahn uh between
cologne and bonn at a very high speed
and there was a certain sign that he
kept seeing wondering what it was
um and i'm german speaker so i
translated it for him and he couldn't
believe that there was such a word it
was
um it's not even scatological but it's a
funny little word maybe a little off
color and he said are there any other
words like that and i said well there
are many combinations to that he said
well what are they and i proceeded to
speak them in german
and he said write those down for me will
you and i wrote them down on a piece of
yellow paper and he looked at it and
laughed and put in his pocket well
uh every other time we would see each
other from time to time he would mention
this incident but he didn't that time
and i said well do you recall our little
trip down the autobahn
and
he looked
for a moment as if he were looking at
the sky and
cocked his head in that in an inimitable
way and it took just a few seconds and
he said yes i do
and normally he would have had it just
like that so i remember wondering and i
have these marvelous pictures that were
taken
by bill fitzpatrick the former white
house photographer who was at this
particular gathering
i remember those very well and i
treasure those pictures because it was
the last time that i saw him and shortly
thereafter he
composed this exceptionally moving
letter to the american people talking
about going into the sunset of his life
next call independence kansas good
morning good morning uh mr allen i was
wondering if you could tell us how close
to demise the president was and also
i was wondering how c-span knew the
tapes were in your bag
i'm very curious about it well first of
all that's part of the great the great
center of the road conspiracy c-span
conspiracy i suspect
um
um
it's called luck
it wasn't in the green room the bag was
here we took a chance and
okay that's your that's your version
we'll go with that one uh i can't
comment really because i'm not uh i'm
not medically competent
but i don't think the president was was
close to dying but he could have had i'm
told had there been a greater loss of
blood but remember he walked into the
hospital and was only the upon walking
into the hospital with his knees buckled
beaumont texas good morning for richard
allen thank you i'd like to ask who were
the republicans and how long before
reagan was inaugurated were they
negotiating with the iranian iranians
about the iranian hostages in their
release on his inauguration day that's a
great question it's also the subject of
another program it's called
as well let me just stop and answer it
this way
i helped or did create the term october
surprise
and it was a very interesting device to
be used during the 1980 campaign
because we thought there might have been
another attempt to rescue uh the
hostages in the part of the carter
administration you have to wait for a
book i'm slowly writing or and having
good intentions about
till you'll hear the full story about
this
but
the october surprise came back to haunt
us
because
a
staffer on the
national security council gary sick who
was on
the carter national security council
staff and whom i retained for a short
period of time later came to the
conclusion
that
george bush bill casey and i
flew to paris to
in 1980 during the campaign to petition
the iranians meet with them secretly
to petition the iranians to keep the
hostages until after the election so
because we would give them a better deal
or for whatever number of reasons there
were two very large investigations
ultimately
by the congress senate investigation and
a house investigation
such august organs the new york times
editorialized about this ted koppel ran
a couple of night line shows it was an
absolute it was a it was a hoot it was
an absolute hoot
it later turned out that on the day that
uh
bush george bush and i were
alleged to have
flown to paris
uh i was doing meet the press
and he was at a country club in chevy
chase maryland at a breakfast or a
brunch
um
but
the the theory lives on you can find on
the internet and the great october
surprise has never yet been adequately
treated and as soon as i have time and
finish that part of my work uh you'll at
least have another point of view and i
think it will be as authentic as you can
get i might add also that mr gary sick
one of the key originators of this
conspiracy theory
once on mcniel error
public television promised that if he
was proven wrong he would apologize to
president reagan and to others involved
that apology has never been forthcoming
i don't expect it either our guest is
richard allen who is a graduate of notre
dame and is currently a senior fellow at
the hoover institution his article
appears in the atlantic monthly it's
called the day reagan was shot based on
recordings that took place on the
afternoon of march 30th 1981 in the
situation room at the white house also
if you're interested in hearing the full
conversation you can go to our website
at cspan.org also can read the article
at atlantic monthly next call is from
overpeck ohio good morning to you
good morning how are you doing today
thank you well
i'm a veteran of grenada panama and the
desert storm so
i have many fond memories of the bush
and reagan administrations
two quick questions
one could you explain to some of our
listeners what the bohemian grove is and
the owl
also uh could you give a corollary as to
what you actually think we should do
with our military now to build it back
up to the the place it was before
well um
those are two good questions i guess the
bohemian grove
is i'm not a member i might add but i've
been a guest several times particularly
martin anderson of the hoover
institution ed fullner of the
heritage foundation
it is a it's a club in san francisco
that was originally founded to promote
art literature and culture drama
and the the the grove
is belongs to the club and it's about
100 miles
north of san francisco on the russian
river in a beautiful sequoia grove
redwood forest
and there's a lot of legend about it
it's men only
and
people go
to certain encampments there must be 70
or 80 of these campsites on various in
various parts of this enormous grove of
redwood trees it's magical it's very
interesting place
plays are put on there are serious
lectures and discussions heads of state
and government come from all around the
world
and you live in conditions of complete
informality and great intellectual
stimulation for whatever period of time
you're there
and the encampment takes place i think
there's a spring encampment and there
might be a fall encampment there's also
summer encampment and many guests come
and go it's a very big and well
organized thing it is
absolute delight and
the waiting list to get in is
sometimes 15 or 20 years
and i would i would go back in a
heartbeat if invited
with regard to the military
i can say that
the
my hope is restored
having participated once at a time when
the status of american military forces
was um in disrepair
that is in the in the reagan uh campaign
and having participated and been
sometimes responsible for aspects of the
the get well program of american
military readiness
uh i think we're ripe for another
round of that
the reagan buildup was done basically by
spending a lot of money but it was also
part of a strategy a grand strategy
president reagan uh far from being
enamored of weapons
was a man who believed deeply in
disarming in fact he was the most
ardent disarmer that i've ever met in my
life
and it was born of that theory or that
that belief of his that we came to
ultimately to strategic defense
initiative to the so-called star wars
but in the meantime his view was that if
he didn't want an arms race the american
people don't want an arms race
but if there's going to be an arms race
we're not going to lose it
so working
with his campaign advisers during the
during the campaign and then immediately
upon
uh becoming president
he decided that we would have a military
buildup and we did
and it was that that was a major factor
along with many other important factors
that
a rivulet so to speak that flowed into a
major stream
that that ultimately
won the cold war because it was
president reagan's intention not just to
manage the cold war or to deal with it
but literally to win it and he laid down
the conditions that ultimately won the
cold war the military is an extremely
important part of that but not the only
part petersburg virginia good morning
with richard allen yes sir did you can
you hear me
yes indeed okay i'm just wondering
because i didn't get an answer to my
first question chris matthews and mike
barnacle are doing a story now on a
relationship between neil bush and scott
hinckley and so i was wondering why
you did not address the question that i
was trying to ask which was that i see
well which was that the cia
and the
fbi had told
the white house the day of the shooting
the scott
and
neil busch were very close friends
between castle weinberger and george
such they told the fbi and cia not to do
an investigation until they got back to
them they got back to them and told them
there was no conspiracy let me just
mention
i i don't know
but i can tell you one thing george
schultz wasn't in the administration at
the time and if the cia and the fbi had
made such a request to the white house
on its way to the president would have
come across my desk i have no
recollection of any such request slidell
louisiana good morning caller
karen good morning good morning
gentlemen mr allen the prime one of the
primary responsibilities for the
president of the united states
is to ensure the security
of
the people
also foreign policy
the president
uh
when sending and helping the iran contra
and so on
uh giving them arms and then taking the
arms and sell and giving them or selling
them to
colombia
not colombia that
country in south america who we were
helping fight
the terrorists
i think you mean nicaragua powers act
is a result of that
what was the question what power as a
result of that
well i i won't discuss that particular
problem it's been well hashed over but i
would say that the power
of the president
to conduct foreign policy is
constitutionally based and it's also
based in a steep tradition and the
choices that a president makes
our policy choices
any policy choice is basically
defensible and president reagan had a
reason for doing what he did before we
let you go last july july 30th actually
in the new york times you penned an
article called george herbert walker
bush the accidental vice president
i did what's behind this
well that's that's a 20-year perspective
but that's not the name that i gave to
the article because i don't consider the
george bush vice presidency in 1980 his
selection by president reagan to have
been anything of an accident at all it
was a result of some very serious
considerations
but
that was a
drama that
i happened to witness and it was unusual
for a foreign policy advisor to be there
that night but i happen to be also the
only person who never left president
reagan's side that night and i took
some very detailed notes
of and the time down to the minute and
the time uh the the time in the seconds
and um i decided that it would be
on the 20th anniversary of the
republican
nominating convention to write the story
uh in a way that had not been written
before and to lay down some of the facts
and uh those facts comprise the the
backbone of my article george bush
was is a man i've known since he came to
congress in 1966.
i happened to be give him one of his
first foreign policy briefings when i
was at the hoover institution on war
revolution peace well before my time in
the nixon campaign
i met him we became friendly we have
remained close friends over many years
he had asked me to help him in 1980
actually well before 1980 but i was
already firmly committed
to president reagan and when the time
came to make a suggestion
about
george bush's vice president i obviously
was
more than willing to make that
suggestion it was a critical moment but
bottom line there was talk but no deal
between then former president ford and
then governor reagan there was yes
former president ford was touted to be
the vice president by a number of people
there were negotiations going on there
was a deal in progress but the deal was
not consummated and it was important
that a choice be made that night and
that choice was suddenly
george bush and uh
i
was there it was as it was uh
as was all going down so to speak
there was a picture of several of us
standing there and i was taking notes i
i guess i was the only one who took good
notes that night richard allen thanks
very much for joining us we'll let you
take those tapes back in your briefcase
you're not trying to take them
not at all thank you for sharing some
time with us delighted
energy continues to be one of the key
topics focusing uh the time and
attention here in washington in a moment
we'll continue our discussion about cole
you're watching c-span's washington
journal it's thursday march 22nd
do
[Applause]
[Music]
join us this sunday for the business of
books when we'll take a
behind-the-scenes look at walker and
company the independent publisher of
best seller